hey everybody is Charlie so a whole
bunch of flash injustice - gameplay
trailer stuff so I'm going to play this
they'll be an injustice to giveaway at
the end of the video so I'll explain
everything after the gameplay and the
trailer and joy is awesome so he killed
the dinosaur so flash went back in time
and back in time and to end they there's
two timelines going on yet in the same
super moon and they intersect at the end
that's correct
and look at that first off that looks
awesome
I don't really have you know that I was
good I was talking to Ed today uh yeah I
got some Caggiula - yes look I got some
really cool flash costume credit for I'm
like there's one of them work flash
looks like a sports car this is like
he's like a sports car it's amazing
alright so the first ability we have
equip is the head dive which is a dive
kick but instead of a kick uses head
because we've got to mix it up yeah he's
flashing pretty dead it's a quick
overhead attack and when you have a
character power acting that looked like
one of the most fun things and is
probably my most fun thing about my
rallies bounty what if you're having
trouble against dr. fade or dead shot or
maybe you're fighting beaten you want to
keep them out what what could you
possibly do or something ever throw
something at umm so now he has a
projectile he does there's another
existence in one of the ability
abilities you have for your ears or your
custom loadout if you're having a really
hard time and you've always thought I
love the splash but I wish I had a
fireball there you go so what's the
difference between the regular version
and the mirror record the regular one
doesn't do a whole lot of damage and it
just kind of stumbles them back and here
everyone's a little bit slower but the
trade-off is you get a big chunk in
Panama ah oh I really like that blue
that's pretty neat alright so a lot of
people have been asking
that a lot of you coming up in this
custom loadout you can now what this
does for you is flashes free up early
the D is actually people continue combos
if I didn't drop them seems like they
went to the school of Lansdowne combo
and this is a tremendous entire if you
phone it is in the vicinity was at all
they're going to pick down now also the
business excite this is super exciting
oh come on you got to pick a level for
clothes ooh that's wise is waiting so
poor building anticipate right yeah yeah
Niners approaching a nailed it don't
talk turn intro oh we're doing intros
this week's that's where oh boy alright
I'll try not to talk how's your mother
Mary you were the one weren't you I'm
every bad day you ever had
begin gonna let him sit there for a
little bit
yep so that ladies and gentlemen is
reverse-flash one of our premier skips
we'll talk more about those as time
comes on I bet times the time moves on
but that is reverse-flash we're not
going to do any with the mother sit baby
I see an intro we'll play with those
more in the future we want to give you a
sneak peek of your first look at one of
our first games and you can see that he
has his own line
we need help don't we not his
not that guy anymore look I get why you
don't trust me but you should trust the
Guardians this ring means something they
put me through hell to get it back
don't worry bet with this crew on the
job what could go wrong what comes next
mere mortals cannot stop we both knew
when it come to this fate will not spare
you
your wish you had
all day I've been reminded how I failed
to be a hero
how many more innocent people died
before you accepted some lies need to be
taken we both knew it would end this way
in a few short hours we break the yoke
of oppression my mole in gorilla City
says garage planning something big but
what where when we don't know our time
that's called
[Music]
I'm over she
you're just asleep
today the world welcomes its new masters
deities
and more than a few society members
[Music]
today we show the world that we are
Muriel
we bring anyone who a gas and again
welcome we're happy to check out but
you're coming with that
nice aim Deadshot just get the job done
you
so that just looks so cool so I cut that
way down I can post more injustice flash
stuff later if you guys want but they're
just showing off some of his combos I
love that he goes back in time for his
super move so appropriate maybe we can
blame flashpoint on him instead of on
Barry on the flash TV show but he's got
a couple different costumes we see eel
bar thongs reverse-flash costume for the
first time
everything looks so much cooler than the
first injustice and I loved it edy Boone
called the Flash's first alternate
costume they showed off the white
costume with the helmet looking like a
sports car
we got a flash costume that makes him
look like he's wearing a sports car so
let me know which flash costume do you
think is the best so far just remember
you unlock your armor as you win new
matches so you can make these look even
cooler and unlock new abilities so just
like I said at the beginning of the
video there's a new round of the
injustice to giveaway I'm giving away
presale copies it's not like a physical
copy because the game hasn't come out
yet it's just for pre-orders so all you
have to do to enter be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video there'll
be plenty more DC happening in the next
couple days you guys have asked for a
Darkseid video for the movie that is not
for the injustice to game injustice to
Darkseid is also going to be really cool
too and because the game's not coming
out for a couple more weeks they're
still going to be releasing gameplay and
trailers and a bunch more cool stuff
like this so while you wait for that
next video you can click here to learn
how Deathstroke the actor almost plays
Superman in the DC EU and you can click
here for a brand new flash thank you so
much for watching let's high-five I'll
see you guys in the next video